hi I'm Christopher hind today we're
going to talk about my third Kumi Joe so
this is my third form it is ridiculously
similar to cyos sensei's 10th form and
again all of my forms are based on cyos
Sensei I I think he did an excellent job
in compiling them and the stuff that's
in there um it's just I use a different
ordering and I talk about things
differently there's some things
specifically that I stress that cyos
Sensei says is not a big deal and
something cyos Sensei says is a big deal
that I don't uh hopefully I'll explain
everything and why I've made those
choices um but that's basically it so
we're going to go over my third Kum Joe
today I'm going Josh out here we're
going to go to work
Josh all right so uh right now we're
going to talk about the third Kumi Joe
that I teach um and this is just about
the same as cyto sensei's uh 10th Kumi
Joe this is the last of the Kumi Joe
that are regular weapon stance to
regular weapon stance after this we're
going to go to a benign stance right
like a a jokai um so like if you're just
chilling out and someone attacked you so
this is the last of the heads up um and
honestly we probably have most all of
the stuff you're going to do weapon on
weapon interaction covered in this um so
a big chunk of the syllabus is contained
in these three and a big chunk of the
tactics are contained in these big three
okay so in this one unlike the other
ones we are in ski Kamai for Josh and
kin Kamai for me and uh we are in
distance for Josh to step in and hit me
okay now understand this is a really bad
distance for me cuz wall it is still
possible to hit Josh I'm not really
hitting him ideally and he's in his
perfect range to hit me so um he's got a
little bit of an advantage in this
stance also I'm going to be clumsy
dealing with the weapon like this it's
not going to be as good so when Josh
attacks me I have to have some way to
transition this so I'm going to
transition from a kinami essentially
into a ski Kamai right so I'm going from
a narrow uh grip St a narrow grip to a
wide grip as I do this because the wide
grip is going to be better for me in
close so as Josh comes in I use the
backside here to defend so I'm pushing
that away then I want to get my weapon
in use right so now if I wanted to stab
Josh while I could stab him over here
I'm going to pull it all the way around
and reset up to stab here now this again
could be spear theory if you were
looking at the spear tip as I get here
and defend I want to turn it back over
so I can reuse my spear tips so we're
going to go through this full set here
so as I'm here like this I knock this
aside I spin it over and I'm ready to
use it now as I'm getting ready to use
it Josh comes in again so I step again
and I defend this right and I'm pushing
it away now as Josh comes this next time
all the Slack's going to be gone we've
gone to a narrow stance I'm here at his
elbow so controlling B basic EO I'm
going to roll over the top I'm going to
come back and get him this way okay
let's switch sides here and we'll talk
about the rest of it okay so what's
happening here is we're at a close
position and Josh is in a more favorable
position than I am so my first thought
is I got to get out of this distance and
I'm going to back up right so I want to
make distance for myself now when Josh
sees me make distance for himself he
does what we do in a lot of the forms
which is transition J hu bang right so
now he's set up for that okay and he
manages to do that faster than I can get
my weapon around the way I want it right
so I'm not going to be in the ideal
position yet so I'm about here and right
when he comes in oh I'm in a bad way now
if I had got it over faster I could just
go into first form right so understand
that if we're here and I got over faster
I could go here right into first form
okay but I'm kind of in the interim here
and he comes in again so I use the
backside again boom to defend myself
okay now he's coming in on me so I'm
going to eat up all the slack so I'm
going to take away his kin Kamai
Advantage by crowding him so here when I
push it away I'm coming in at this guy
right and then as I do that I'm scared
he's going to hit me right so if he
comes and makes a little bit of room he
could hit he can hit high or low right
and he can do all kinds of stuff so what
I'm going to do is right after I do that
I'm going to track him down I take a P
That Elbow right and that gives me
control so now it's hard for him to hit
me now as he continues through I come
down I catch his neck I apply pressure
from the back in here and that squeezes
his neck and then I can drive him back
for a CAG right so I get a choke and a
CAG but what we're seeing in this form
is a lot of changing in distance and how
we change our ideals right so this is
teaching us how to transition short to
long and long to short right so Josh uh
and and we've been working with this a
lot in the forms is understanding the
same concept that if I get really far
back he should transition into a long
long attack stance okay I seeing that
and getting caught underwear decide to
start transitioning into a closer stance
right so wall we're in the middle of all
that I go here and boom okay and now as
he comes around one more time in the
long stance still I crowd him even more
right and this is eliminating a lot of
the advantage he has with the weapon in
that position I come back here boom I
choke and I drop off this is my third
form if you take one two and three they
all play really really nicely together I
can show you how they all link up and in
fact in the next set of videos I will
show you how they all link up up um but
these three are really really valuable
this is from cyto sensei's 8 n and 10 so
I think what he tacked on the end is a
real interesting set to tack onto the
beginning um for mine so um those that's
my third Kum Joo this is Joshua T I'm
Christopher hin my salon behind that
camera right there see you guys in a
future video